je voulais aujourd'hui avant que la
musique ne reprenne
remercier infiniment de notre part à
tous jack lambert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du coup c'est vrai que l'extinction
rébellion est surtout connu pour ses
actions coup de poing ses actions de
blocage à voix de comploter au bloc des
rues en le déplaçant d'organiser des
assemblées populaires pour décider
ensemble de ce qu'on a envie de faire
pour lutter contre le climat on se
réunit une fois par semaine et on fait
plein de on discute on organise des
actions moi j'ai bien bloquer des trucs
dont je bloque des trucs après tout un
rappel à la loi un rappel à la loi et si
je devrais images et j'aimerais dire
c'est un peu comme comme quand tu es
petit tu ta mère te dis
allez maintenant il ya peu de choses
dans la vie politique ont fait qu il
reste quarante ans après encore et qui
sont des pratiques aussi populaire
effectif
[Musique]
donc c'est une source d'inspiration pour
chacune et chacun et voilà avec la
ministre de la culture et nous toutes et
tous je voulais qu'on puisse lui rendre
cet hommage et je le remercie de sa
présence